so
my name is jose martin garcia i work on
several projects in at warframe one of
them
being the jio project so as in previous
conferences i'm going to be presenting
the more computational aspects
of the additions this year
for dio
so the main thing for us this year or
one of the main things
is the change for from
having geographics backgrounds being
mostly based on images
to geographic backgrounds that are
vector based um so this means
that this year we will be reviewing
uh vector geoprimitives
we will see a new objects we have added
called geopolygon a function geo
boundary to compute
boundaries of two dto primitives
and then i will focus on two aspects
that are particularly demanding
of computation regarding vector
geographics
i should say that in the next talk
francisco will be
talking also we'll continue talking
about
vector geographics and this year
the separation between computation and
data
was particularly difficult so to make
both
talks self-contained there will be some
overlapping
in the topics we uh discuss
okay so let's go with the first uh
part well here i have a map similar to
the one that stephen showed yesterday
and this is a map
of around the area of
the eiffel tower he was showing
yesterday the area
around notre dame
with the same style um
here as i was saying everything is
vectorial every
building is a polygon every street is
a line where we have labels text
objects etc everything is vectorial here
and so these will allow us to
be a lot more powerful
in the specification of styles and
also the images of course will be the
results will be
crispier and now you will be able to
enlarge the maps as much as you want
so regarding primitives i want to start
by having this table in which we see the
various primitives
that we support in the jio project
until now we have used this
combination of flat primitives with your
position
information inside we will continue
using that of course
and but i would like to focus today
on the more geo-defined primitives those
that are defined
on the surface of the earth and have a
very definite
geometrical meaning so in zero
dimensions we all
had the marker already and in this table
we see
the column with two d primitives the
column with one d primitives and the
relation between the
left column and the right column is just
bundling
so we will be adding these two objects
just to complete the table see
and so the boundary of a geopolygon will
be a geopath the boundary disk
it's a geocircle geohemisphere
has its own primitives for the rendering
the visible region the same thing the
bounce region we add
this one again to complete the table and
then we have these
two special cases of geohemisphere
depending on time
with boundary date night terminator
so i want to start by reminding you
of the geometric meanings of these
subjects
so geodesic and your silicon are
the simplest ones so we have
uh here at the circle center around
rome with 3000 miles of radius and
the boundary is this one
so the definition of these objects is
that they are formed by radiuses
that are geodesics themselves so this is
clearer
if we select just a range of initial
angles
right so in this case we see how we have
this object formed by
all these radiuses which i've selected
just
in terms of 15 degrees and this is the
corresponding geo circle
so now for example if we compute the geo
boundary this is the new function of a
geodisc
we get of course the gsl core with the
same center the same radius
now if we have a deal disk
that has only a finite or well not
complete
um range of
angles then you see that we get these
more complicated objects the reason for
that
is that now of course we need to
uh give only also these two
lines these two geodesics as
part of the boundary so this is what
this is doing is joining
this segment and the 2g6
okay so the visible region and its
boundary
i think i haven't explained here in
detail what these
do so what we take of course this is an
earth which is highly exaggerated in
eccentricity
so what we do is that we take a point
over the surface
we could put it further away
and we see how the visible region uh
changes what we are doing here is just
tracing lines
and so the the point in which the lines
from this point are tangent
to the ellipsoid are those that define
these
uh invisibility region here
right so that's the thing and
the interesting thing is that these we
are moving the point along this line
this red line
and there is a transformation from this
angle to that other angle
and this is the vector which is always
perpendicular to this line this line
happens to be an ellipse
and it's on a flat plane so what we are
doing is just cutting the earth
with a plane and just where to put that
plane depends on the position of that
point
it's very simple so if we take for
example
that point at an elevation of 400
kilometers
we can compute the well we can describe
this is the visibility region
the geo boundary would be as we were
saying the visible region boundary
of that same point and now we can
uh just draw the 2d region and the 1d
boundary
and we are doing this with with one of
the new
vector styles
the hemisphere is a particular case of
visibility from
infinite length so now
we have exactly the same diagram but now
the point is infinitely far
from the center of the earth and the the
plane
with which we are cutting the earth
happens to go
through the center of the earth and so
these the lines that are parallel to the
red arrow
will be tangent to that point and that
point and the same thing happens
so we have now geo boundary computing
the boundary of the
of the hemisphere
here we have a hemisphere and its
mandarin
and the particular there is a particular
case in which we put a date here or an
instant
and this is able to give us the
hemisphere
that this is the night hemisphere so we
are in this part
daylight and this is the boundary
between the
night hemisphere and the hemisphere
that's very simple too
this one is defined as uh this is a new
object
which we have added for completeness and
this is a just a rectangle in latitudes
and longitudes
it's very simple and so we have that
object that's the giobanz region of the
u.s
so it's bounding in latitudes and
longitude
the u.s and this is its boundary
so yeah and this is another
of the styles francisco will explain in
the
next talk these various styles we have
now
okay so let me introduce the new object
geopoli so geopolygon corresponds to the
2d
region of geopath and it has several
interesting properties that i want to
discuss today
so let's take some latitude and
longitudes
points so we have these four points
right so we put them
in this object the polygon now if we do
a geographics
of the subject we get that
what we see here is that it's
automatically computing
the geodesics so meridians are geodesics
but parallels are not so this point and
that point
are not joined by a straight line they
are joined by that
geodesic same thing happens on the south
and south hemisphere
so what's the boundary of that
geopolygon of course it's a geopath
which by default also uses geodesic
segments so we can draw it
and we draw it also as an arrow
so we see that we are following the
points of the boundary
in counterclockwise
order this will be important in a moment
following the new polygon with holes
notation we also specify holes in the
same way
so we put our boundary our outer
boundary
a row and then the list of holes which
in this case is just
the same points divided by two
um
yes so that's the whole and you see how
the judicial
has different curvature uh on the on the
on the map okay so what's the geo
bundling of that object the geo boundary
will be now a geopath
containing two independent segments this
one
and that one so let's think so
two independent geopaths for example
these also again following a polygon
will have the multi polygon notation so
we can have the object we had before
plus this object which has been it's the
outer one
shifted by 50 degrees and so now we see
these two objects and you see how they
are always treated independently so if
they overlap they overlap
your polygon will not stop to analyze
those
overlappings the boundaries now of
course
now we have three lines so this the
multi geopath
containing the one two
and three lines of points and
notice also how the lines must have one
point more
in order to be closed right so we
started with four points
the boundaries have five points
yeah those are the boundaries okay
so something interesting is the
following if i'm given
just one of these lines how do i know
which side of the earth
do we want so most of the systems out
there
for gis for geo work
impose the restriction that the polygons
must have
at most half of the earth in extent but
we don't want to do that
so geopolymer has now second argument in
which you can specify in various ways
which side of the earth you want so for
example we can say i want a smaller area
i
will give that or i want the larger area
and then it will return that one
which is a complementary one
or for example remember that we were
traversing the points in a
counterclockwise
way so
we can specify that we want the left
area as we traverse the points
or the right area as we traverse as we
traverse the points
another in possible way of specifying
which side you want is by specifying an
exterior point
or by specifying an interior point
this specifies the exterior point to all
the lines here
this specifies the interior point for a
particular
outer line here so these are
the same specifications so this is a
north pole so that that point of a dial
would be exterior
this is an interior point which is this
one so so we get the same thing
we can do the opposite we can now say
that the interior
uh sorry the exterior point is zero zero
so if this is exterior
to that line it means we want that area
here
or if you want that as interior north
pole is now interior then
we mean that one
okay another thing that we
want with uh is that
by default geopolygon is adding segments
not as straight lines in the map but as
geodesics
we can specify now
the possibility of choosing some other
type of
of segments say a lock strum and of
course when we compute the boundary
it will inherit in the geopath which
type of
geopath we are using so now we see the
difference with the
diagram before so uh both
parallels and meridians are loxodromes
so
we get that and this line is also
different from that
so you see how geopolygon now allows you
to specify multiple things
so it's a it's a it's a very flexible
geoprimitive the
general geoprimitive from now on into d
so what can we do so here there are a
few examples now with geopolygon
we can express the whole world as a
single object
so this contains the same points that
our current
specification of the band of the
what polygon has but we are now doing it
with field curves and lines and
the position etc this has directly all
the numbers inside
with holes for example notice how the
caspian c
is a hole in this other big polygon
so this has more than a quarter mil of a
million points and
more than 6000 lines because there are
many islands
so that's something we can do now
expressing the whole world in a single
object
for example as i was saying before if
you are given the points of the equator
how do you know
which sides of the world you want
so right so we are given those points
and again notice how we are giving them
in a definite order
so we can say give me the hemisphere in
which i am
here or the one that contains the north
pole
or give me the opposite hemisphere to
where i am
or the one containing the
southpaw another thing that can be
now treated better is antarctica so what
we always did with antarctica
is that in order we had a line that goes
from one side of the
from from minus 180 degrees to plus 180
degrees
longitude and to specify which side of
the world we wanted
what we were doing was to specify where
to close
in a rectangular map meaning we were
giving two points
very close to the south pole
so if we add the boundary of that
geopolygon
what we see is this line a very very
small circle there and the line
comes back and continues so now
i can express antarctica just with two
pointless
which are the two points that were given
here so this had
1387 this has 1385 it's just the
the line from one side to the other side
but now of course we can compute the
boundaries the bounds and it goes all
the way down to -90 exactly
and if we plot it the g boundary doesn't
have that line so it's just
this closed line so this is the sort of
topological
computation that we can do now better
with geopolygon
and finally one more example of how to
compute
holes imagine that you are given these
two lines
this one and that one so how many
possibilities do we have
well the simplest one is to say they are
independent regions
i put them there and there inside your
polynomial so these are multipolygon
they're two completely independent
regions
now we can say that one is a whole of
the other and this is interesting
now i can say line one is the outer one
and line two
is the inner one or vice versa
effectively
the two situations are identical i'm
just saying
here in these two notations that the
both lines
are boundaries of the same connected
region
and the the main difference is that in
this case
this is the the exterior the canonical
exterior point
region while here will be here
but they both express the same situation
or we can now say for example
take the two lines and specify that
this point 0 minus 80 is exterior
so that point is exterior so from the
point of view of this line
obviously we need to get that region and
from the point of view of this other
line
and because i have expressed them
separately they are independent
this is also exterior so i want that
right
so this area is covered one this area
here is covered twice
okay so you see how this allows
expressing
various situations as you may need
and finally this was added in version
12.1
but i want to remind you of the
existence of this so this is a
a way of working with
the region's functionality using geo
objects which is very powerful so we
take the polygon
of the us we take some projection with
specific parameters whatever
so that would be the projection we are
using for the world
and what we can do is to project the
primitive we use the
grid position exactly as we do for the
opposition right so we take the u
polygon
project it and now these objects the
polygons that have been projected
can be handled by area and the
other region functions and
they will use the
coordinates that are used in the
projected space
so for example this map is able to
place the us exactly as what
must be in this projection using the
original
polygon of zero degree position but
we can take the geogrid position
directly express it
as a mesh region which of course we can
use exactly as before
it gives you the same area we were
obtaining before
and now we can also put that grid mesh
directly
on the map and as long as we are using
the same projection here and the
projection we used
for projecting this object
which was hidden here then it would all
match
and once you have this grid mesh you can
use all the region functionality
available
in both language that's very powerful
okay so that was the main part
of the talk and then i want to quickly
cover two algorithms that we have
developed to work with vector tiles
and um that are particularly demanding
from the point of view of computation
so i want to show you here how the data
comes
from the use server in tiles
and
here this is the case of sum 0 in which
the whole world comes in a single tile
it's just that one and we see how we get
polygons
lines which are all these borders and
points these points are prepared for
placing labels there francisco will
explain that and then
um right notice also how
the uh the ocean is the actual polygon
the for example all of eurasia is just
uh background right so you see how this
this
border of the polygon enters here
america in this case is just
a hole in the polygon right like
australia etc
right so this has random colors and the
data comes from openstreetmap
so if we do the same for zoom2
what we get here are again lots of
primitives
and you see how they come tiled and also
very important
there is a buffer region in which the
neighbor
tiles overlap so this is inconvenient
for further computations
so something we want to do is to merge
them and we have to merge them very fast
so we have developed functionality that
is able to take that
structure and in a very small fraction
of a second
it's able to give you this other
equivalent structure
in which still this is just a single
polygon of the
of the oceans and america is still hole
in that polygon
but we have a single structure right now
and this is done at all zoom levels for
example this is zoom
8 around chicago and you see
again here the structure of tiles this
is extended throughout the whole
map you see for example here how these
two regions match
or there etc so we merge them into a
single structure
and that is what we see again
francisco will explain later how this
whole thing is then styled and then
in one of our new styles it will look
like that
okay we
are treating those objects also as we
treat our
geo primitives with projections so they
come in a very particular projection
mercator data and so this is a function
that constructs
the projection we need so um
[Music]
right so here i've just taken the lines
of the previous map
put them there and you see how we can
handle them or
in any projection so this would be the
the original
something i forgot to mention is that
the data comes in integer values
so that that helps a lot emerging all
these polygons
because we do not have to deal with
rails
okay but again all these lines can be
extracted from the previous map
and then you have at your disposal all
the data
in the time and uh very quickly the
final
second algorithm that i wanted to
comment is about how we place labels
so this is again something quite
demanding
because some situations have tens of
thousands of labels to
handle so we need something fast we get
three types of labels labels for points
for lines for polygons
and the priority is to avoid collisions
between them
so what we do is that we have developed
efficient r3 algorithms
and i want to show you an example so
this
is just a function to compute a number
of boxes in this case it's just a
thousand boxes
and for example they are those boxes so
many of them
overlap so we put them here in this
function
that for the moment is in a private
context but we hope to be able to expose
it
in the future and you see how in a
fraction of a millisecond
is it selected nearly half of them
and then we have that result right and
so we could have taken
100 000 boxes now i'm not going to plot
it it will be totally black
but the important thing is that it's
still in a fraction of a second
we can select about 2 000 boxes that do
not overlap
right
and then many of the boxes come rotated
what we do rather than having to compute
overlappings with trigonometry which
would slow our r3 algorithm
what we do is that we break these
labels into several boxes so that
the cover doesn't extend very much the
areas this is the number of boxes we are
using so the the larger it is the more
boxes we need
but the important thing is that this can
be done in
any direction we can also shift the the
center of rotation if needed
because sometimes the boxes the labels
are shifted and then these are
these oriented boxes which are the ones
that are very efficient in arteries
are the ones inserted and so now we can
easily
do that sort of thing
my last slide is about labels of
of of lines so here you see for example
the sangamon river
how we placed it three times and so what
we do is that the algorithm
takes the river considers all the
possibilities
here there it ranks them the opacity
is the ranking so these are this is beta
etc and then it selects three that are
far apart enough
and yeah it could move them to one side
if needed
okay so it's almost time so version 12.2
has experimental support of vector
geographics
these may that made us improve our
hundreds of zero primitives
and now yeah we have developed
especially
demanding computations as new algorithms
that we
hope to expose
okay and let's see if i see that
francisco and brett has been
answering questions
so i actually don't think i have much
time
but i do recommend you go now to uh
francisco's talk
and he will continue discussing the
data and styling parts of vector
geographics
okay i leave it here thank you bye